[Musique]
bonjour à tous c'est l'heure de
politique à table sur LCP avec notre
invité Grégoire de Fournas on va parler
alimentation agriculture cuisine
écologie un petit peu politique et avec
moi pour le cuisiner Jean-Pierre
Montanet bonjour Jean-Pierre bonjour
Brigitte et bonjour Grégoire de
formation alors vous êtes députés
rassemblement national de la Gironde
depuis 2022 vous avez fait partie de
cette vague RN aux dernières
législatives qui a permis à 89 députés
rassemblement national et bien de faire
entrer leur entrée au Palais Bourbon
vous aviez raté la marchand 2017 alors
que vous étiez déjà investi dans la
ville haute qu'a en tant que conseiller
départemental du Nord Médoc vous êtes
également conseillé municipal du côté de
Pauillac alors Pauillac Médoc ça sonne
bon l'appellation viticole car vous êtes
viticulteur vous avez d'ailleurs tenu à
nous apporter le vin un médoc bien sûr
mais pas le vôtre et pour l'accompagner
quoi de mieux qu'un plat à base de vin
jambon et du rouge pour préparer un
boeuf bourguignon et un dessert une
douceur du cru le fameux cannelé
bordelais dans le dessous des plats quel
vin demain sur nos tables avec le
réchauffement climatique les vignerons
cherchent des solutions reportages en
Provence dans les pieds dans le plat
faut-il interdire la chasse au moins un
jour par semaine la question en chante
les promoteurs les promeneurs mais fait
hurler les chasseurs et on en a un sur
le plateau
[Musique]
mais dites-moi quand même au-delà de ce
message politique vous l'aimez ce plat
j'espère oui je l'aime beaucoup surtout
que c'est un c'est un plan un plat de
mon enfance c'est c'est le bœuf
Bourguignon alors c'est une petite
infidélité au bord de lait que je suis
parce que un peu péché c'est ce que
j'allais vous dire
totalement Chauvin il faut savoir
s'ouvrir aux autres cultures en
l'occurrence sa culture de domaine tout
à fait mais non mais c'est un plat j'ai
choisi parce que c'était un peu de mon
enfance et puis ça aussi un plat
populaire le bœuf Bourguignon c'est
c'est fait avec les les morceaux de
seconde choix du du bœuf économique ou
l'ennemis
tout à fait et puis c'est un plat
authentique voilà vous avez une recette
familiale qu'il préparait chez vous ma
maman évidemment et c'est vrai que
évidemment parce que parce que mon papa
oui j'ai vécu dans une j'ai grandi dans
une famille assez traditionnelle où mon
père
il est toujours d'ailleurs viticulteur
et et
si frères et sœurs parce que nous sommes
7 et donc celle qui fait la cuisine
voilà enfin
du dimanche c'était un peu déception
d'anniversaire du dimanche tout à fait
mais donc ce sont des bons souvenirs et
puis et puis je m'en suis fait aussi ma
petite spécialité voilà
tout à fait le secret du bœuf
bourguignon c'est le temps de cuisson
voilà il faut pas hésiter à le faire
cuire longtemps parce que c'est pas
forcément une viande qui est qui est
bonne voilà mais enfin avec la cuisson
les choses viennent et puis chacun son
petit secret moi c'est de mettre un
petit peu de chocolat dans la sauce et
ça permet de voilà ça permet de rendre
la sauce un peu plus onctueuse le goûter
puis nous dire si Françoise le fait
aussi bien que votre marrant je n'en
suis pas sûr et pendant ce temps là
Jean-Pierre trois choses trois astuces
plutôt sur le bas pour réussir son bœuf
bourguignon alors bien faire mariner la
viande que vous aurez que vous aurez
conseillé votre boucher dans le vin
rouge avec pourquoi pas des oignons des
carottes des épices comme le clou de
girofle des herbes aussi teint laurier
au moins 24 heures 24 heures bien la
faire mariner dans le vin c'était le vin
de votre papa quand votre maman faisait
le vin rouge ou pas du tout oui d'accord
il est plus pratique
enfin quand même alors c'est donc cette
marinade c'est le secret d'un boeuf
tondre moelleux et parfumé et vous
pensez bien à la fin à recueillir le jus
de la marinade que vous pouvez employer
alors avant de briser la viande
c'est-à-dire de la faire cuire longtemps
comme la dit Monsieur de Fournas faites
la saisir et doré sur tous les côtés les
sucs au fond de la marmite vont doper le
goût de votre bourguignon alors la sauce
très importante attention à ne pas avoir
une sauce épaisse genre béchamel surtout
pas de maïzena pas de fécule pas de
farine et essayez plutôt le chocolat et
voilà l'astuce il l'a aussi monsieur de
fondas avec deux petits carrés qui vont
lier votre sauce pour adoucir l'acidité
du vin je vous conseille aussi de jouer
avec une cuillère de miel dans la sauce
enfin astuce au dernier moment râpé du
zeste d'orange dans cette sauce et ça
lui apportera une touche un peu raffinée
d'agrumes c'est exactement comme ça que
vous le voulez
pas il faudrait il faudrait essayer si
le vin est pas de très bonne qualité un
peu acide c'est pour ça que je faisais
pas en fait
ce bœuf bourguignon il est très bon ce
qui est bien c'est qu'il est resté il a
été cuisiné de encore une fois de façon
assez traditionnelle et authentique n'a
pas été revisité parce que c'est
toujours un peu un peu décevant quand on
a des plats traditionnels qui sont qui
sont voilà on est ça veut dire quoi
revisité
la même générosité enfin mais là c'est
c'est très bien la viande est très très
bonne donc c'est vous mettez des petites
carottes il y a des champignons des
champignons des carottes
et des pommes de terre et des pommes de
terre et puis on peut mettre aussi un
peu de lardons un peu de mettre des
lardons effectivement et le 20 alors on
se pose toujours la question est-ce que
ça vaut le coup de mettre une bonne
bouteille dans un plat comme ça lorsque
20 va cuire longtemps ça va mijoter
c'est pas c'est pas forcément
déterminant pour faire un Bourguignon il
faut un vin corset quand même assez
assez fort et voilà on peut jouer sur un
petit vin économique c'est pas la peine
de mettre une bouteille à 40 euros dans
un soyons raisonnable quantité vous le
congelez vous le réchauffez après dans
la semaine ou non on fait ce je fais ça
la veille voilà le samedi matin pour le
dimanche matin c'est très bien et puis
ça le temps de cuire pendant le faut
faire une comme une grosse marmite quoi
voilà
tout le monde apprécie parce que ça
goûte 20 mais c'est l'alcool est parti
en fait tellement cuit que même les
enfants peuvent la cuisson il faut on
peut rajouter un peu de vin on peut
aussi rajouter de l'eau quand même pour
éviter de
est-ce que vous prenez du plaisir quand
vous faites de la cuisine quand vous
faites ce bœuf bourguignon oui après il
faut avoir le temps de le faire voilà
mais vous prenez du plaisir monde de le
faire oui bien sûr et vous avez pas
essayé de développer d'autres recettes
puisqu'on brigitte a dit monoculture
Monoprix je suis pas je suis pas très
aventurier mais après c'est encore une
fois c'est vrai que c'est une question
de temps là il faut
surtout quand on fait quand on est
viticulteurs qu'on fait de la politique
à côté vous l'avez dit ça fait quand
même pas mal d'années que je suis
investi c'est toujours un peu compliqué
oui bien sûr et vous aimez
particulièrement les plats traditionnels
bourguignon on a souvent de la
blanquette aussi dans dans cette
émission parce qu'en fait la la
gastronomie la gastronomie française est
quand même assez riche pour que on est
on puisse prendre le temps de la visite
voilà et puis c'est cette variété de
tradition de de spécialité locale fait
quand même que
je suis voilà pourquoi pas de temps en
temps s'évader un peu sur d'autres
recettes d'ailleurs mais finalement la
gastronomie française encore une fois
est assez riche il faut qu'on puisse
quand même en profiter et puis sans
satisfaire sur ce vin si vous le voulez
bien qui est donc un vin du Médoc c'est
vous qui nous l'avez apporté donc de
Gironde c'est le long de l'estuaire
c'est une appellation sous régionale le
Médoc c'est si je me trompe pas avec au
médocs grave Blaye code de Côtes de
Bourg ou l'Entre-deux-Mers et c'est un
petit peu moins connu que les
appellations communales comme Pauillac
ou vous êtes vous vous habitez vous êtes
pas loin de Pauillac il y a Margot il y
a Saint-Julien il y a quoi encore
Saint-Estèphe et puis les cépages alors
pour ce médoc à Bernay soubignon
Cabernet Franc Merleau Malbec petit
verre d'eau c'est un millésime 2011
pourquoi vous nous l'avez apporté vous
pensez qu'il se marie particulièrement
bien avec ce bœuf bourguignon
c'est assez charpenté donc effectivement
il se marie bien avec ce avec ce plat et
puis c'était c'était voilà voilà j'ai
pas pris mon mon vin parce que je
trouvais ça un peu un peu mal venu mais
je suis allé je suis allé j'en ai pris
une bouteille chez une voisine Christine
couriand en l'occurrence qui est
viticultrice qui a un certain c'est une
c'est une personnalité voilà et puis qui
qui était à la tête d'une exploitation
de ces hectares et qui est qui fait ça
de façon encore une fois authentique
c'est ces petites exploitations
familiales c'est un trésor en fait dans
le dans le Bordelais puis elles ont
tendance vous dites authentique ça veut
dire quoi exactement bah parce qu'elle
elle cherche à garder l'authenticité
l'authenticité de son métier
c'est-à-dire qu'elle est exactement
exactement et puis c'est une
exploitation donc elle a hérité de son
père donc il y a cette idée de
transmission familiale qui est une belle
chose ce qui est aussi mon cas et puis
donc viticules depuis 1983 en gardant
alors évidemment modernise la façon dont
on produit le vin mais on garde aussi de
certaines traditions elle a fait le
choix de
regarder les vendanges manuelles et elle
a eu cette phrase qui est d'ailleurs
assez amusante parce que évidemment pour
les faire les vendanges manuelles et
fait appel à des saisonniers et elle
disait je ne suis pas contre la machine
avant danger mais si si je vends jamais
la machine à manger avec qui je pourrais
danser le soir donc c'est quand même
assez une phrase assez amusante et
surtout ça c'est c'est encore une façon
de de faire de l'agriculture avec cette
convivialité cette qui est assez
intéressante c'est vrai quand on voit le
le phénomène d'industrialisation
finalement de l'agriculture on perce ce
vrai vivre ensemble
à la machine mais comme comme 90% des
viticulteurs bordelais qui a besoin de
beaucoup de main d'oeuvre étrangères
justement pour faire les vous en avez
conscience vous
dit par exemple cette viticultrice c'est
oui je suis pas sûr que ce soit vraiment
la elle elle voulait vraiment garder par
c'était vraiment un choix un choix
agricole mais c'est vrai qu'à cette
difficulté de trouver de la main
d'oeuvre pour un pour un travail qui est
effectivement très pénible et pas
justement très bien payé alors pour
revenir un peu sur vos goûts culinaires
vous aimez un peu cuisiner vous avez pas
le temps mais vous aimez manger déguster
faire ripaille est-ce que vous aimez ça
vous êtes gourmand parce que le parce
que le comment dire le repas c'est avant
tout la convivialité évidemment donc
c'est alors ça peut être en famille moi
je suis très attaché au repas du
dimanche en famille voilà parce que
c'est le moment où on attend exactement
on a on peut inviter les les parents les
ou les grands-parents et et et puis il y
a aussi les autres moments les autres
moments les les repas de chasse par
exemple qui sont toujours des choses
tout à l'heure tout à fait agréable
arroser un peu peut-être on verra ça
avec modération évidemment mais
c'est c'est aussi important voilà c'est
le repas c'est vrai que c'est un moment
de convivialité c'est important de
garder et moi je tiens aussi dans
l'éducation je donne à mes enfants de
pouvoir garder ses repères qui sont
alors moi j'ai pas du beurre bourguignon
à tous les repas familiers qu'est-ce que
vous aimez qu'est-ce qui vous fait
kiffer comme alimentation comme plat
la viande oui c'est vrai que
du barbecue parce que parce que le
barbecue c'est un moment de convivialité
et puis c'est aussi un moment où on
arrête de se poser des questions
existentielles qui qui sont pas
forcément très adaptés à la situation
voilà parce qu'en fait
souvent on voit
le que le charbon prêt n'est donc c'est
pas c'est pas forcément une opération
facile
du charbon de bois des braises oui ça se
fait assez naturellement en fait on n'a
pas besoin de se poser encore une fois
de se poser des questions
ou quelquefois même au set de vigne
enfin c'est un peu ce qu'on a sous la
main mais voilà c'est c'est ça fait
partie de ces traditions françaises vous
balayez de la main toutes ces petites
polémiques on a pu entendre qui ont
alimenté
à votre barbecue non mais très très
sincèrement ce sont des questions que
certains idéologues se posent mais moi
je j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un dans le
Médoc se poser ce genre de questions
enfin il faut être un peu déconnecté
finalement de de ce qui se passe dans
dans notre pays pour pouvoir arriver à
se poser des questions pareilles et
d'ailleurs je vois que c'est même cette
polémique a fait réagir même au sein
même de la du pêche donc c'était pas
forcément voilà une question très
intelligente alors on va voir si vous
êtes vraiment incollables c'est le quiz
alors comme viticulteur comme amoureux
des vins vous avez sans doute du nez
pour juger la qualité des nectars mais
seriez-vous nous dire aussi lequel de
ces aliments est le plus malodorant
alors à le surstromming c'est hareng
suédois fermenté plusieurs mois oui ça
doit ça doit être quelque chose
B l' œuf de 100 ans c'est une spécialité
chinoise c'est un neuf chinois macérer
notamment dans la boue et dans la cendre
enfin c par enfin mais c'est le tofu ce
fromage de soja puant ça veut dire ce
que ça veut dire et dès le duriane qui
est un fruit d'Indonésie quelle est
cette l'ingrédient l'aliment qui est le
plus malodorant alors je n'ai jamais
consommé aucun des quatre aliments dont
vous dans j'imagine
moi j'imagine que c'est celui-ci
puisqu'il enfin en tout cas s'il fallait
faire un choix je ferai celui-ci alors
je crois qu'ils sont très très mauvais
il te faut plus mais le pire c'est le
durian ou du Ryan je sais pas fru à
cause de son odeur pestinentielle il est
même interdit dans les lieux publics en
Indonésie ou en Malaisie
siècle le bouchon de liège imputrescible
quels sont les premiers à l'utiliser ah
les Italiens B les Anglais c'est les
Néerlandais et des Espagnols
anglais néerlandais espagnol c'est
peut-être les Anglais je vous avoue ce
sont les anglais ce sont les Anglais
[Musique]
vous vous avez des bouchons plastiques
parce que maintenant et on a des
traditionnel alors le bouchon en liège
en soit évolue on est plus forcément
dans le bouchon traditionnel
c'est-à-dire que maintenant le bouchon
c'est du même modernisé mais on reste
dans cet aspect traditionnel c'est
important c'est important de garder
cette authenticité encore une fois et
c'est ça vaut aussi pour le bouchon puis
on a des bouchons maintenant qui bougent
très bien on a pu ses problèmes de
bouchon avec l'évolution des du liège
c'est plus un problème parce que je vous
dis encore on a fait des on a fait des
progrès sur le sur les bouchons vous
rajoutez une autre une autre matière ou
le liège améliorer ce sont des Liège
améliorés qui peuvent être en partie
aggloméré enfin voilà il y a des
manières de bien mais j'ai répondu les
anglais parce que c'est vrai que le
Bordelais est très connu pour avoir
exporté beaucoup de vin depuis fort
longtemps en Grande-Bretagne et donc
c'est c'était peut-être une manière de
prendre conserver
ils viennent ils viennent d'où vous
fournisseur est évidemment le
fournisseur du coin mais je pense qu'il
vient tout ça vient du Portugal
la part de délocalisation qu'on a pu
faire dans le
bouteille de vin mais mais
acheter
les bouteilles se viennent d'Albi le et
puis après le 20 c'est une production
locale voilà et alors comment vous
consommez vous vous allez un peu faire
le marché parce que vous cuisinez que le
bœuf Bourguignon ça on a compris mais
est-ce que vous achetez chez les
producteurs locaux est-ce qu'il y a du
troc je te donne une bouteille de vin tu
me donnes un kilo de tomates comment ça
se passe
sur le marché de Pauillac qui est un qui
est un marché qui qui résiste encore
heureusement et puis après on a un
certain nombre de bouchées nous on a les
éleveurs de de Gironde qui se sont très
bien organisés pour créer eux-mêmes leur
boucherie ils ont d'ailleurs inauguré
très récemment leur nouvelle abattoir
donc on est vraiment dans le dans le
circuit court et puis dans le
surtout dans un modèle qui gagnant pour
les pour les éleveurs parce qu'il
maîtrisent toute la toute la chaîne de
de transformation et puis de
commercialisation ce qui leur permet
quand même de vivre correctement de de
leur métier mais voilà donc c'est du
local mais pas du bio on voit que le bio
baisse un peu parce que c'est cher aussi
est-ce que vous vous achetez du bio non
c'est pas un choix moi que c'est pas un
critère de décision en tout cas quand je
vois pour des raisons économiques ou
parce que vous n'êtes pas sensible à
d'abord pour des raisons économiques
parce que
non parce que moi
je je suis un viticulteur en ce qu'on
appelle en conventionnel donc je sais
aussi qu'il y a une part de
d'exagération dans le dans la
diabolisation qu'on veut faire de
l'agriculture qui n'est pas biologique
et puis pour l'aspect économique parce
que parce que le bureau effectivement
est plus cher donc c'est pas voilà c'est
pas c'est pas un critère un critère qui
est le mien dans le dans le
bio dans les chez les viticulteurs
que vous avez aussi une évolution vers
le bio mais là on voit une évolution ou
donc ou des ou des beaucoup
d'agriculteurs reviennent sur le sur les
choix qu'ils ont fait ce qui d'ailleurs
une décision pas facile parce que on
sait quand on passe au bureau il y a
quand même des années de transition donc
ils sont des investissements exactement
mais parce que oui mais enfin qui ne
couvre pas non plus le sur tous les
pertes de récolte parce qu'en fait la
grande difficulté du bio c'est pas
l'adaptation de du machinisme c'est
c'est surtout accepter de faire des
récoltes qui sont moins importantes et
dans la vie de culture on le connaît
c'est-à-dire que des années qui ont été
difficiles comme l'année dernière par
exemple avec le mildiou c'est c'est
extrêmement compliqué d'avoir une
récolte satisfaisante qui permette la
rentabilité en fait de l'exploitation
c'est pour ça que vous avez pas fait ce
choix là c'est vous pouvez pas vous
permettre d'avoir une récolte plus
faible très sincèrement moi je ce que je
vois avec la bouillie bordelaise on
arrive à traiter la vigne de manière
très difficile ça vous impose d'avoir
plus de matériel pour pouvoir traiter
plus souvent il y a aussi l'entretien
des sols qui est extrêmement difficile
en agriculture biologique ça suppose
aussi d'avoir plus de personnel ce sont
autant de coûts de production qui qui
sont qui sont difficiles à absorber
surtout quand on est des récoltes qui
sont moins importantes mais c'est pas
forcément c'est aussi un marché mais il
est limité c'est que c'est pas un marché
qui permet à l'ensemble de l'agriculture
française et en l'occurrence de la
viticulture de pouvoir de pouvoir s'en
satisfaire et ces stratégies qui
voudraient nous dire alors qui est pas
forcément porté par tout le monde mais
quand même par certains qui voudraient
nous dire il faut que l'ensemble de
l'agriculture passe en agriculture bio
ça veut dire que demain les agriculteurs
auront les contraintes du bio en vendant
au prix du conventionnel c'est ça passe
déjà dans la filière et au-delà de la
viticulture dans votre région vous
sentez qu'il y a une baisse des
conversions par exemple du du classique
au bio il y a beaucoup
en tout cas c'est des chiffres qu'on
qu'on nous donne surtout dans les dans
la céréales mais mais en tout cas on il
y a un très fort scepticisme dans la
viticulture c'est clair on voit pas
forcément un modèle gagnant qui soit
évident pour pour
ne parle pas alors on sait qu'en France
le repas occupe une large place et c'est
souvent autour d'un bon plat que ce nous
les meilleures histoires que ce fait
même la petite et la grande histoire
c'est la brève de comptoir
alors Grégoire de Fournas on vous a
demandé de réfléchir à une anecdote
autour d'un repas en politique ou autre
est-ce qu'il y a une histoire qui vous
est revenue particulièrement à l'esprit
très honnêtement j'ai un peu cherché
mais j'ai pas j'ai pas vraiment trouvé
mais c'est peut-être l'occasion de vous
parler d'une tradition viticole
qui est la gerbode qui vient de gerbe
d'ailleurs c'est cette bouquet de fleurs
qu'on a eu peur
de fleurs qu'on accroché qu'on accroché
à la dernière remorque de l'avant des
des vendanges et qui donc revenait vers
le chèque qu'on accroché ensuite au mur
du chai niquez devenu dans les années
qui ont suivi cette fête de fin de
vendanges qui est assez qui est encore
pratiqué donc un grand repas qui permet
de célébrer la fin des vendanges et
voilà j'ai pas forcément une anecdote
mais en tout cas j'avais cette belle
tradition tout le monde chante
évidemment c'est surtout c'est un moment
de d'abord de soulagement parce que un
viticulteur depuis l'apparition des
premiers bourgeons on écrit évidemment
pour le gel pour les pour la grêle enfin
pour un certain nombre d'intempéries
jusque à la dernière remorque qui rentre
dans le Chéché c'est un moment de stress
et quelquefois des des nuits sans
s'endormir beaucoup d'anxiété face aux
prévisions de la météo et effectivement
quand on rentre la dernière remorque
dans le chez c'est un moment de
soulagement et donc un moment festif
alors on va passer à présent au dessous
des plats et on va parler du
réchauffement climatique parce que
évidemment et bien les viticulteurs
comme vous doivent s'adapter à ces
changements et chercher des solutions
c'est le dessous des plats
[Musique]
le dérèglement climatique oblige les
vignerons à s'adapter les dérogations
pour arroser son de plus en plus
nombreux cherche certains cherchent de
l'ombre par tous les moyens d'autres
innovent en plantant des cépages venus
d'ailleurs reportage en Provence de
Stéphanie desperres
pour affronter les sécheresses il y a 5
ans ce producteurs de rosé installé un
réseau d'irrigation sur la moitié de son
domaine l'eau arrive du Canal de
Provence un kilomètre d'ici qui arrive
l'eau
jusqu'au jusqu'au bout du rang et on a
un goutteur à peu près tous les mètres
c'est
Var en général Jean-Marie Eric une fois
en juillet une fois en août mais cette
année cela n'a pas suffi le mois de mars
jusqu'au jusqu'au vendanges avec des
chaleurs incroyables donc là on a fait
un troisième apport au cours de l'été
mais voilà entre deux et trois apports
dans l'été sont largement suffisants
mais si on n'a pas ces apports là
l'avenir rentre en souffrance et on a
des problèmes derrière
qualitatifs sur les raisins avec des
blocages de maturité il a aussi fallu
avancer la date des vendanges de
mi-septembre au 25 août par le passé
voilà on sait pas de quoi l'avenir sera
fait mais ouais c'est plutôt inquiétant
cette année exceptionnelle pourrait
devenir la norme paradoxalement ça a été
sec et chaud à limiter les maladies la
récolter bonne 2022 s'annonce donc comme
un bon cru mais cela ne dissip pas les
inquiétudes de Jean-Marie quand il fait
trop chaud il y a trop de sucre dans le
raisin et pas assez d'acidité les gens
cherchent plutôt des vins légers pas
trop alcooliques malheureusement le
climat nous en empêche donc quelle
technique on va pouvoir mettre en place
à part la date de vendanges pour avoir
moins de sucre et moins d'alcool dans
nos vins si on change pas nos techniques
probablement disparaîtra demain alors
il expidité la fertilité du sol
et surtout il voit plus loin avec cette
petite parcelle pas comme les autres ça
c'est un Plantier de vertero qui est un
cépage espagnol résistant à la
sécheresse ça c'est la base plus
résistant aux maladies plus tardif que
les cépages qu'on a actuellement chez
nous en mars dernier
en deux nectar de ce cépage espagnol
pour voir s'il poussent en terroir
provençal on est plutôt content du
résultat pour l'instant il se comporte
bien il y en a pour au minimum une
décennie de valider des essais qu'on
fait ici donc et que dans 10 ans c'est
que le climat sera encore plus extrême
donc il faut vite vite s'y mettre on est
presque presque trop tard mais bon 5
c'est pas étrangers peuvent désormais
être plantés en Provence sous la
surveillance attentive du syndicat des
Côtes de Provence gardiens de
l'appellation une fois qu'on aura les
premières récoltes on regardera les
caractéristiques du vin parce que la
finalité quand même l'un des points
principaux c'est que les codes de
Provence restent les produits qu'on a
l'habitude de consommer et que les que
nos clients et nos consommateurs
connaissent s'il essaye concluant les
futurs cuvées du Domaine de la morigue
contiendront du raisin
issu d'un cépage espagnol
Grégoire de Fournas est-ce que vous vous
avez aussi dû vous adapter à cause des
fortes chaleurs ces dernières années
on n'a pas eu toutes les années
vu se réchauffement climatique on a eu
aussi des années très récentes où on a
eu beaucoup de pluie pas beaucoup de
soleil donc c'est vrai que cette année a
été très particulière et on a vu dans le
Médoc beaucoup de beaucoup de vignes
souffrir mais après il faut quand même
voir si dans les années futures
effectivement ce ces années exceptionnel
vont souvent se répéter il y a pas de
réchauffement climatique vous êtes pas
vous le constatez pas forcément
climatique parce qu'il y a des la grêle
ou pas
mais je voudrais pas que sur une année
particulière on en tire des conclusions
on a eu 2003 aussi qui avait été une
année très très chaude on avait beaucoup
de beaucoup de sécheresses et de
canicule on a eu la sécheresse de 76
donc c'était aussi des années
particulières elles sont évidemment
toutes différentes mais je pense qu'il
faut quand même voir un peu plus loin
avant d'en tirer des des conclusions et
puis après on s'adaptera c'est ce que
c'est ce qu'a dit ce viticulteur vous
n'avez pas le droit de
[Musique]
dans le Bordelais assez exceptionnel
mais sur certaines appellations
mais écoutez on verra mais je pense que
la viticulture comme l'a montré ce
viticulteur justement est capable de
s'adapter on peut changer de cépage on
peut aussi planter à d'autres endroits
c'est que dans le Médoc on a ces groupes
de graves peut-être que et puis on
laisse les parcelles un peu plus en bas
fond pour l'élevage peut-être qu'il
faudra aussi évoluer on verra on
s'adaptera il faudra donc vous parlez
encore au futur alors que tous ceux
qu'on a vu il parle au présent
en tout cas on y réfléchit mais
par exemple
de façon générale dans le Médoc en
avantagé plutôt mais si vous voulez dans
le Bordelais on a quand même on n'est
pas dans le dans le sud de la France
comme c'était le cas dans votre portage
on n'est pas non plus en Espagne en
Espagne on fait toujours du vin alors
que les chaleurs sont quand même plus
importants donc des températures plus
fortes qui font que vous avez un taux
d'alcoolémie qui est plus important
dans vos envies si vous voulez pas
encore dans le Bordelais on est quand
même plus au nord que que que
effectivement la vue des degrés qui
était important mais c'était pas non
plus
[Musique]
plus problématique que ça mais il y a
plein plein de marges de manœuvre donc
je vous ai parlé de lancer page man le
lieu de plantation on peut aussi baisser
la quantité de feuillage parce que c'est
que c'est le feuillage qui produit le
feuillets c'est ça non
parce que la vigne rogner mais on
pourrait rogner plus bas voilà réduire
encore une fois la quantité de feuillage
c'est plein de pistes à
explorer après moi je suis sur une
exploitation qui est moins touchée par
ça mais je sais que d'autres qui l'ont
qui l'ont connu notamment à Pauillac
sont en train d'y réfléchir c'est ça
fait partie des pistes de vous imaginez
que vous puissiez planter de la dans le
Médoc demain qu'on puisse faire du vin
dans les hauts de France ou en Bretagne
ça vous permet l'avenir encore une fois
il faudra il faudra
si vous voulez j'ai du mal ça a été
d'ailleurs le cas en Gironde sur les
incendies de forêts vous savez on était
très important nous on essaie de tirer
des conclusions sur long terme de
d'épisodes exceptionnels est-ce que les
épisodes exceptionnels sont sont pas
justement très exceptionnels voilà c'est
toujours la question je suis pas sûr
qu'en 2003 quand on a connu cette
canicule qui est encore une fois a été
aussi très importante on se soit dit ça
y est ce sera comme ça toutes les ans en
l'occurrence il a fallu attendre
quasiment 20 ans pour pour que ça se
renouvelle donc mais encore une fois moi
je vous dis il y a eu d'autres années
l'année dernière ou ou d'autres années
récentes ou on a manqué de soleil on a
dû on a dû énormément de pluie donc
c'est c'était aussi de d'autres
circonstances on vous écoutant je sais
pas si c'est le point de vue de Brigitte
et j'ai quand même l'impression quand
vous écoutant on sent pointé un peu de
climato sceptique quand même c'est pas
le cas mais mais je ne suis pas non plus
dans l'excès inverse qui vise finalement
à instrumentaliser des événements
climatiques pour en tirer des
conclusions non mais Languedoc par
exemple les vins étaient à 14 degrés en
moyenne dans les maintenant alors qu'ils
étaient à 11 degrés dans les années 80
alors le Languedoc c'est plus au sud
vous avez raison mais c'est un phénomène
qui commence à toucher tous les
vignobles vous n'êtes pas inquiet vous
pensez pas que la vie ne peut
disparaître en France bah l'évoluera
peut-être que effectivement peut-être
qu'il y a des régions on fera moins de
vignes et qu'on ira les on ira les
replanter un peu plus au nord mais 14
degrés pour le Languedoc ça ne paraît
pas non plus complètement délirant c'est
plutôt le 11 qui qui est un peu
surprenant donc finalement les choses
s'améliorent les années 80 donc il y a
un cépage espagnol qui arrive en
Provence il faut changer du coup les
appellations il faut parce que c'est en
fait c'est interdit on préciser sa
capellation il va falloir peut-être se
dire qu'on pourra accepter des cépages
étrangers ou du sud de la France en
Bourgogne ou en vous savez pour
combattre le philosophe une maladie très
grave de la vie on a on a fait venir des
des porte-greffes américains donc
finalement voilà ce genre d'évolution
n'a été capable de le faire il y a déjà
50 ans donc encore une fois c'est pas
forcément un problème ce qui est ce qui
est important effectivement c'est ce que
disait
la personne dans votre reportage c'est
de garder quand même une certaine
authenticité alors évidemment il faudra
pas non plus que on produise du vin
espagnol dans le sud mais il faut il y a
pas que cépage d'ailleurs il y a aussi
le la manière de de cultiver la vigne de
de vinifier qui qui perdureront et vous
la composition de votre vin vous vous la
modifier quand vous avez des années
chaudes comme ça pour avoir un peu plus
d'acidité vous mettez peut-être un peu
plus de Cabernet que de merlot si vous
voulez on vendange ce qu'on a donc on
adapte pas les cépages en fonction des
années parce que on va pas replanter des
vignes tous les ans mais en tout cas
dans le choix des CUV et que qu'on
élabore et évidemment c'est ce sont les
20 assemblages donc on si on veut faire
une cuvée un peu plus haut de gamme que
qu'une autre on va on va choisir un
cépage ou un autre évidemment mais oui
ça fait partie du travail du du maître
de chez vous vous êtes beaucoup pardon à
la vigne vous vous travaillez beaucoup
la ville vous avez encore le temps de le
faire ou depuis que je suis élu très
sincèrement j'ai voilà j'ai réussi quand
même à aider mon père pour les vendanges
mais lui-même qui a fêté ses 62 ans
penser pouvoir voilà faire cette petite
transition cette préretraite et là voilà
depuis le mois de juin il a il a dû
assumer beaucoup de choses tout seul et
je le remercie d'ailleurs voilà mais
après ça fait partie des des difficultés
de la vie politique qui sont pas
forcément très graves mais c'est
beaucoup de réorganisation ça c'est
clair donc j'avais une petite question
très précise j'ai lu qu'à cause du
dérèglement climatique il y avait de
plus en plus d'incendies et quand les
incendies se produisaient à côté des
vignobles ça pouvait donner un goût aux
vins est-ce que votre avis avec vous en
avez fait allusion c'est feu gigantesque
et historique en Gironde ça peut avoir
une incidence sur le goût du vin voilà
vous savez que dans ma circonscription
au mois de au mois de septembre il y a
eu l'incendie de somos ou les 3000
hectares qui ont brûlé qui c'est un
insolite qui était moins important que
les deux gigantesque de La Teste
Landiras mais c'est un sandwich a eu
lieu justement au début des vendanges
donc il y a eu effectivement cette cette
crainte parce qu'il y a en plus il y
avait des nuages de fumée qui envahi le
Médoc et cette crainte que surtout si la
fumée est rentré dans les chers au
moment des remontages ou le ou le 20 est
au contact de l'air il y est il y a un
goût de fumée qui soit dans le vin et
finalement on n'a pas eu de il y a pas
eu de problème donc voilà c'était
heureusement tout s'est bien tout s'est
bien déroulé quand on parle de
réchauffement climatique c'est aussi
bien plus de chaleur mais c'est aussi
des épisodes de grêle de gel de froid
intense comme on a connu en revanche
l'année dernière l'hiver dernier ou même
au printemps dernier est-ce que
aujourd'hui les viticulteurs peuvent
faire face à ces dérèglements climatique
je parle financièrement et qu'est-ce que
vous pensez des assurances qui ont qui
ont été mises en place
alors les assurances elles sont elles
sont importantes parce qu'effectivement
quand vous quand vous quand vous grêlez
et surtout quand vous grêlez à 100%
comme ça a été le cas dans beaucoup
d'endroits c'est non seulement récolte
qui est perdu mais c'est aussi la
difficulté pour la ville de pouvoir
repartir et donc de fournir les
correctement enfin de produire
correctement pour les années suivantes
alors les assurances elles ont la rôle à
jouer c'est vrai que jusqu'à maintenant
elles ont elles ont pas été efficaces
parce qu'il y a eu des critères qui ont
fait que n'étaient pas opérante il y a
une réforme de l'assurance récolte qui
qui était bienvenu même si c'est quand
même un peu compliqué de dire aux
agriculteurs en général que c'est eux de
financer finalement se dérèglement
climatique si un dérèglement climatique
il doit être assuré finalement par le et
vous vous êtes assuré parce que la
plupart ne l'était pas enfin c'est ce
qu'on s'est rendu compte je suis alors
cette année j'ai pas subi de d'aller à
climatique heureusement mais je sais que
que beaucoup qui ont grillé notamment
n'étaient pas assurés c'est évidemment
dramatique mais en fait la première
difficulté c'est pas de celle de subir
les événements climatiques qui sont pas
nouveaux encore une fois moi je me suis
enfant d'une gel de 1991 qui a été
terrible pour le la viticulture
bordelaise notamment mais à l'époque les
viticulteurs arrivaient à se relever
parce qu'ils arrivaient avant de
correctement leurs vins donc il y avait
des mauvaises années mais finalement les
bonnes permettaient de faire une bonne
moyenne là ce qui est très difficile en
ce moment c'est que la viticulture
bordelaise traverse une crise très grave
avec des situations très difficiles et
évidemment un gel ou une un orage de
grêle c'est c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment c'est pas ce qu'il fallait dans
cette situation
alors on va passer un tout autre sujet à
présent et on va parler des accidents de
chasse qui sont survenus assez nombreux
depuis la reprise de l'activité alors
faut-il durcir les règles les différer
on en parle et on met les pieds dans le
plat
oui
Brigitte alors que la saison de la
chasse basse son plein à plusieurs
accidents dramatiques en quelques
semaines on fait deux morts et des
dizaines de blessés ravivant ainsi le
débat sur la coexistence entre chasseurs
d'un côté habitant et promeneurs de
l'autre comment éviter les balles
perdues comment mettre fin à cette
guéguerre qui fait rage dans nos
campagnes faut-il interdire la chasse le
dimanche c'est un reportage de Pierre
Michael Carniel et d'André Lafont
donc ça c'est le chien quand il est
encore vivant il s'appelle Eloy il était
vigile dans une bijouterie le samedi
matin il reçoit une balle par un
chasseur
au fond des bois et moi par la même
occasion étant à environ deux trois
mètres de lui je reçois un fragment dans
le ventre pour nous Isabelle debouver
revient sur les lieux de l'accident dans
sa propriété du Loir-et-Cher alors
qu'une enquête est en cours elle ne
comprend toujours pas comment le
chasseur a pu confondre son chien avec
un sanglier
le poste de chasse du chasseur se trouve
ici
donc il était donc là
j'ai reculé à la trace rouge qu'on fait
les gendarmes et de là il a donc tiré le
chien qui est environ 60 mètres sachant
que il faut calculer un angle de tir
mais sachant qu'il tire le chien à cette
position et moi je suis là donc on doit
dire 1 m peut-être je sais pas
légèrement blessé c'est désormais la
peur au ventre qu'elle se balade et tout
le monde est terrorisé plus personne ne
marche plus personne ne court les gens
rentrent leurs chiens leurs enfants le
week-end parce qu'ils reçoivent des
plombs sur les toits parce qu'il
craignent de prendre une balle perdue
quand d'autres vont courir dans le
chemin communal un chasseur se met en
travers leur dit méfiez-vous c'est
dangereux passer votre chemin comme
autant des brigands donc je pense qu'il
faut faire quelque chose et je pense que
le minimum ça sera au moins un jour par
semaine sans chasse pour que les gens
puissent être libérés et se promener en
toute tranquillité sans crainte de se
faire assassiner une journée sans chasse
il n'en est pas question pour le
président de la Fédération réformer la
chasse pour pour ça ça sert à rien on y
est on est au top je vous dis
franchement ça va être tellement là
dessus que de toute façon ça fait comme
la personne qui est au volant de sa
voiture qui est un feu rouge il souhaite
il fait pas attention il le brûle ben
voilà c'est la même faux d'inattention
donc le chasseur on peut lui le former
tous les jours tous deux fois par
semaine deux fois par an là-bas quand
l'accident doit arriver il arrive Hubert
Louis Vuitton a toutefois un conseil à
donner au chasseur j'ai un slogan ici
dans le Loir-et-Cher ne pas tirer est un
acte de chasse voilà et ça il faut que
les gens quand ils partent le matin la
chasse et bien ça en tête
depuis l'ouverture de la saison en
septembre on dénombre déjà une vingtaine
d'accidents en France l'an dernier le
bilan atteignait les 90
[Musique]
mais c'est des sangliers qui rentrent
dans les centres-villes c'est des dégâts
énormes sur les sur les cultures vous
savez que la Fédération des Landes a eu
l'année dernière 2 millions et demi de
dégâts à payer ce qui est énorme pour
une fédération de chasse et de des
Landes parce qu'il faut savoir que les
dégâts sur les cultures qui sont
provoqués par les grands gibiers ce sont
les chasseurs effectivement qui les
payent et donc ils ont cette
responsabilité de réguler les
populations de de grand gibier qui sont
bien plus importantes que que beaucoup
d'accidents de chasse en cette rentrée
là qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
faire une excusables qui sont un
chasseur qui dit j'ai été ébloui
c'est pas quand on éblouit est-ce que il
faut évidemment rappeler les règles de
prudence mais dire c'est le cas moi
quand j'ai passé mon permis de de
chasser c'était extrêmement sévère vous
avez des règles qui sont qui sont qui
sont très strictes après c'est vrai que
il y a certains chasseurs qui sont plus
âgés qui n'ont pas eu ce permis de
chasser qui était plus exigeants
on y pense aussi pour la voiture mais au
moins pour rappeler les règles
élémentaires de sécurité après lui il
dit on est au top des chasseur le
chasseur qu'on entend dans le sujet dit
on peut pas faire mieux on est au top on
peut pas lui dire
ça c'est ça c'est très clair et il faut
aussi il faut aussi moi je sais qu'en
tout cas avec les les équipes avec
lesquelles je chasse quelqu'un qui nous
respecte pas les règles de prudence
c'était éliminé de t'écarter mais si
vous voulez si vous voulez non moi j'ai
jamais assisté mais si vous voulez les
accidents de chasse elles ont quand même
été divisé par trois en 20 ans il faut
quand même avoir ça à l'esprit et 90%
des victimes de ces accidents de chasse
ce sont des chasseurs eux-mêmes voilà
donc
ça repart à la hausse ça ne justifie pas
les accidents qui pourraient être fait
surtout dans la situation dans laquelle
enfin la situation que dans laquelle qui
était décrite mais il faut aussi
relativiser celle qui il faut pas non
plus être dupe d'un certain agenda de
certaines personnes qui sont en fait en
T-shirt qui qui veulent interdire la
chasse qui se servent quelques quelque
part de ce prétexte aussi pour pouvoir à
terme
interdire totalement la chasse c'est
d'ailleurs ce que ce qui avait dit
aymeric Caron qui était venu à la même
place où il disait sur cette fameuse
proposition de loi contre des corridas
qu'en soit c'était symbolique mais
c'était un verrou à faire sauter parce
que demain c'est l'interdiction de la
chasse c'est l'interdiction peut-être
aussi d'élevage ce soit demain la fin
de la c'est aymer Caron qui le dit c'est
une étape franchise c'est un verrou
évidemment oui oui parce que quand on
connaît une ricarons c'est derrière la
fin de la chasse la fin des élevages la
fin d'un certain nombre de pratiques qui
sont encore une fois millénaires dans
notre civilisation et qui sont qui sont
parfaitement légitimes et si vous voulez
récupérer ces accidents en essayant d'en
faire un argument pour réduire la chasse
parce qu'on sait que ces stratégies sont
des stratégies du petit pas qui consiste
à d'abord une demi-journée le dimanche
après-midi puis le dimanche et puis le
week-end voilà et puis demain c'est ce
sera l'interdiction totale de la chasse
et moi je ne suis pas dupe de cette
stratégie
votre groupe sur la proposition de loi
sur la corrida je pense qu'il y aura une
certaine liberté qui sera laissée
aux membres du groupe comme je crois que
ce sera si le cas dans un certain nombre
pour l'interdiction on verra en tout cas
on verra aussi ce qu'il y a dans le
contenu de cette proposition de loi moi
très sincèrement
j'ai jamais participé à une corrida mais
en tout cas ce que je vois c'est
l'agenda d'Amérique Caron et ça je le
conteste totalement je
suis pas en soit c'est une tradition
locale qui est qui peut avoir du sens je
suis pas sûr que moi je j'irai en voir
une un jour mais je respecte en tout cas
le la liberté c'est important le concept
de liberté parce que finalement on
l'oublie beaucoup dans ce genre de sujet
la liberté de certaines traditions
locales qui qui sont attachées et c'est
aussi respectable dans ce reportage il y
a un vocabulaire auquel vous êtes très
attaché j'ai entendu le mot brigand j'ai
entendu le mot terroriser j'ai entendu
le mot assassinat et de la part de ces
populations ces promeneurs et là vous
semblez assez hermétique assez
revendications de ces promeneurs qui ont
peur d'une balle perdue qui ont peur de
se faire assassiner ça me paraît un bien
gros mot mais qui ont peur de se faire
tuer puisque ça existe il y a forcément
un enjeu vous savez qu'en fait les
campagnes sont faites très ont été très
urbanisés avec des des néonorures
finalement déjà qui viennent de la ville
et qui ne parlent beaucoup de l'histoire
du coq qui chante le matin mais c'est un
peu le problème aussi avec la chasse
c'est-à-dire que pendant des années ça
ne pose aucune difficulté et puis vous
avez une nouvelle population qui arrive
dans les campagnes et qui pensent que la
forêt d'abord est un est un lieu public
ce qui n'est pas le cas pour l'essentiel
d'entre elles c'est les forêts sont
d'abord des lieux privés ce sont des
défauts privés dans lesquels les
chasseurs y vont encore une fois pour
réguler les populations de de grand
gibier qui sont une menace pour le pour
le pour les forêts mais mais donc il y a
de nouvelles pratiques des nouvelles
exigences qui s'imposent dans le dans la
ruralité évidemment il faut en tenir
compte il faut arriver à organiser aussi
intelligemment que possible la
cohabitation entre les chasseurs et des
promeneurs après il y a certaines forêts
ou les chasseurs sont pas ne vont pas
chasser c'est peut-être la dame en fait
elle est chez elle elle est dans ses
bois elle se promène avec son chien puis
moi
ça conception vous avez un certain
nombre d'endroits qui étaient totalement
naturel et dans lequel on a fait le
choix de construire des maisons et
finalement cette
équilibre a été bouleversé justement par
cette urbanisation qui fait que
effectivement c'est difficile mais
encore une fois moi je je ce qui s'est
passé dans votre portage je n'allais je
n'accepte pas on tire pas sur une cible
qui n'est pas identifié à 60 mètres
c'est pas un comportement qui est normal
et ça il faut le condamner évidemment
vous êtes sur la ligne Willy shrin
qu'ils aillent se promener chez eux
encore une fois il faut il faut il faut
respecter des il faut savoir mettre des
règles les chasseurs en une utilité dans
la régulation des du grand gibier les
promeneurs c'est un liberté légitime et
il faut aussi qu'elle soit on peut pas
on peut pas se promener partout quand on
veut voilà c'est aussi les règles qu'il
faut accepter donc donc il faut aussi
beaucoup de dialogues finalement il faut
réinsérer du dialogue il faut arrêter de
de politiser ou même de
d'instrumentaliser certaines situations
il faut peut-être aussi le travail des
mères pour qu'il soit capable de mettre
autour de la table les gens qui veulent
se promener des chasseurs pour que les
choses s'organisent le plus
intelligemment possible encore une fois
il y a des endroits les chasseurs ne
vont pas n'ont pas chasser c'est
peut-être le meilleur endroit pour que
les promeneurs et se promener il y a le
gouvernement qui réfléchit à un délit
d'Al pour des chasseurs en état des
briétés on se c'est vrai que parfois les
chats s'accompagnent de bons repas après
qui peuvent être rosés c'est pas
toujours le cas c'était pas du tout le
cas de ce chasseur dans notre portage
d'ailleurs mais est-ce que vous pensez
que ça c'est une bonne idée on chasse
pas quand on a quand on a bu au-delà de
j'ai entendu les responsables de chasse
chez qui ça ne fait aucune difficulté
pour la simple et bonne raison c'est que
c'est déjà appliqué dans dans les très
grandes majorité des situations il y a
des repas de chasse qui se déroulent
après la chasse voilà comme vous l'avez
dit donc c'est il y en a qui repartent
chasser l'après-midi
dans un ballon avant d'aller tirer non
non moi j'ai vu des chasseurs qui ne
consommaient pas d'alcool avant d'aller
chasser pendant la pendant la chasse
c'est à dire que les le repas se fait à
la fin de la soie midi quand on a décidé
de nous chasser que le matin ou soit le
soir quand on chasse toute la journée
mais les repas les repas moi tous les
repas auxquels j'ai assisté au milieu
d'une journée de chasse se font
intégralement sans alcool
peut-être aussi pour une simple raison
c'est que les chasseurs ont pas envie
d'avoir un autre chasseur à quelques
dizaines de mètres 2 qui soient
alcoolisées voilà c'est aussi on pense
aussi à sa propre sécurité voilà
comme comme la question des 30 degrés
pour les angles de tir c'est déjà des
choses qui sont apprises dans les dans
les dans les dans les cours de du permis
de chasser et le problème des accidents
finalement c'est ce que vous nous dites
en fait c'est effectivement des défauts
problèmes parce que encore une fois
c'est et d'ailleurs quand on voit les
statistiques dans les dans les accidents
qui peuvent avoir lieu
l'alcool n'est pas les responsable d'un
très très
petite partie des cas de d'accident et
donc c'est finalement pas vraiment le
problème alors après s'il faut légiférer
le faisons-le je veux dire surpris ce
soit pas déjà le cas mais c'est pas
encore une fois c'est pas un sujet allez
on va passer au dessert à présent et
c'est le péché mignon
alors voici le temps du sucré Brigitte
avec une douceur très gérondine le
cannelé qui doit son nom paraît-il à sa
forme de cylindre cannelés il est cuit
dans un moule en cuir qui lui donne une
légère croûte caramélisée alors d'où
vient le cannelé j'ai fait quelques
recherches on ne sait pas bien j'adore
il y a toujours heureusement pour nous
sauver une légende urbaine pour assurer
le storytelling il aurait donc été
inventé dans le couvent des Annonciades
de Bordeaux préparé par des nones pour
nourrir les pauvres la fermeture du
couvent en 1791 a entraîné la
disparition de cette recette qui est
revenue alors je sais pas comment
curieusement à la mode dans les années
80 au point aujourd'hui que le Cadenet
est un peu un must de la Gironde et même
du Cap Ferret d'Arcachon vous adorez ça
le cannelés oui alors après avoir fait
cette petite infidélité avec le bœuf
Bourguignon je reviens fondamentaux il y
a une autre histoire autour du cannier
qui est assez intéressante c'est que
vous savez que pour coller le vin pour
purifier le vin on utilise le blanc
d'oeuf et le jaune donc on se retrouve
avec de beaucoup de jaune qui justement
je l'ai lu aussi a permis cette recette
vous savez les préparer parce que c'est
un peu particulière brigitte c'est tout
c'est vrai mais non mais surtout que la
cannelle est très dur à très dur à faire
il faut avoir un four qui cuit d'une
façon très difficile voilà de cuire
correctement pour qu'il ait une belle
forme une sorte un peu non avec du rhum
il y a de la vanille
que ça il faut avoir les moules aussi
qui sont particuliers donc c'est quoi la
recette d'un bon cannelés réussi il faut
qu'il soit un peu craquant parce que
c'est vrai que les canettes trop mous
sont pas sont pas très bons il faut que
la la croûte soit assez un peu
caramélisée vous savez un peu un peu dur
et puis voilà que ce sont dans
l'intérieur et là ils sont chez François
qui les araignées sont très bons
alors on sait aussi la face obscure du
Cannet c'est qu'il est un peu lié j'ai
lu ça aussi au commerce triangulaire de
Bordeaux
oui peut-être je vous me la prenez bah
c'est à dire qu'on venait
des esclaves et ont rapporté du rhum et
de la vanille et du sucre qui qui
fournissait les ingrédients pour
confectionner les cannelés voilà bon
voilà c'est l'histoire ça vous est où ça
se mange plutôt au goûter ça peut se
manger ça peut se manger au milieu des
cerfs avec un café c'est vrai ce truc on
dit aussi qu'il faut le boire avec du
vin
de Bordeaux évidemment merci à vous tous
de nous avoir suivis on se retrouve bien
sûr la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
numéro de politique à table